chaque praticien va chercher son patient
à l'accueil donc ya pas de gens qui
attendent dans les salles d'attentes une
organisation spécifique depuis le 16
mars pour rassurer les patients
habituels de cette maison médicale
ces patients qui ont notamment déserté
les cabinets médicaux pendant le
confinement par crainte de contamination
certains sont parfois atteints de
maladies chroniques et ont besoin d'un
suivi régulier un phénomène qui inquiète
les médecins
on commence à voir les diabètes
déséquilibres et les tensions qui ne
sont plus équilibrés les les examens
visuels qui n'ont pas été fait on a même
dû vraiment insister pour que les petits
notamment les nouveaux nés soit vaccinée
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas vaccinés
l'impression qu'on a c'est qu'il va y
avoir une crise sanitaire liée aux que
vit une crise sanitaire à cause du coc
vide et une crise sanitaire à cause des
problèmes psychologiques liés au co
vidéo confinement ont évité tout contact
avec le virus une zone spécifique a été
mise en place pour recevoir les patients
qu'ovide 10,9
les médecins généralistes prennent en
charge ces personnes suspectées
d'infection surblouse charlotte masques
ffp2 lunettes de protection nettoyage et
désinfection entre chaque consultation
toutes les précautions sont prises dans
cette zone on voit quasiment plus
personne là on est vraiment jamais vu à
la semaine dernière croit d'accord donc
ça c'est vraiment voilà c'est quasiment
disparu alors maintenant on a on a peur
de d'abord un ou deux cas isolés revenir
donc c'est pour ça qu'on la garde
ouverte au total depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire près de 400 patients
atteints du colis de dix neuf ont été
prises en charge dans cette maison
médicale